ABBA nodding repeatedly pressure the
company to agree to pay or risk having
avenatti hold a press conference that he
claimed would dramatically drive down
the stock price of the company at its
market value as avenatti
threatened in one recorded meeting if
the company did not meet his demands the
company might die but if not it was
quote going to be inflicted with cut
after cut after cut after cut as alleged
the entire scheme played out in less
than a week avenatti first met with
representatives of the company last
Tuesday March 19 in Manhattan at that
meeting avenatti said he represented a
client who coached an amateur highschool
basketball team sponsored by the company
which is Nike the team had recently lost
that contract worth seventy two thousand
dollars a year and avenatti claimed the
coach had information about potential
misconduct by employees at Nike the
allegations of misconduct were similar
in kind to those that form the core of a
prior criminal prosecution brought by
our office that payments were made to
families of high school basketball
players in that meeting and in
subsequent conversations that were
recorded as part of our investigation
avenatti threatened to hold the press
conference at which he would make these
allegations public if the company did
not agree to his financial demands
avenatti promised to forgo the press
conference and allow the company to
avoid financial harm if the company
agreed to pay his client 1.5 million
dollars and for avenatti himself to
retain avenatti at another
co-conspirator to conduct a
multi-million dollar internal
investigation an internal investigation
that the company did not request
avenatti made clear that he was
approaching the company at a time
intended to
maximize the potential financial damage
of such a press-conference namely on the
eve of the annual NC double-a tournament
and the company's quarterly earnings
call as avenatti threatened on one call
cornered during the investigation if the
company did not exceed to his financial
demands and in his words quote I'll go
take ten billion dollars off your
clients market cap then the recorded
meeting the next day with
representatives of the company avenatti
made clear that he expected to be paid
up to twenty five million dollars with
twelve million to be paid upfront and
deemed earned when paid and when asked
by a lawyer for the company why the
company would agree to such an
arrangement avenatti responded in
substance that he had the company in a
very vulnerable position where he could
wipe out five to six billion dollars of
its market capital when the company's
lawyers resisted paying avenatti to
conduct an internal investigation
avenatti told the company it could skip
paying for an internal investigation if
instead it simply paid him 20 2.5
million dollars then avenatti said he
would quote ride off into the sunset
pressure and a sense of urgency were
used in delivering these threats as you
can see from the timeline this all
happened in a period of three days on
day one March 19th of Tuesday this was
the first meeting between a body
representatives from Nike and the
co-conspirator at this meeting a Vinod
for the first time made as a fortunate
demands and threats following that
meeting representatives Nike called
prosecutors in my office and for
tomorrow is of the extortion demands and
threats made by avenatti
going forward all interactions between
Nike represent
and of an update were recorded and
overseen by the FBI at my office on day
two Wednesday March 20th it was a
reported phone call with avenatti the
co-conspirator and representatives from
Nike where our body again made his
threats and in the ends and on day three
there was a meeting which was recorded
on Thursday March 21st well Esther is
that in which avenatti repeated his
demands and threats and as you can see
he graphically described his hold on the
company at the end of this meeting on
Thursday they agreed that there would be
one final meeting the father coming
Monday which is today and that that
meeting Nike would even proceed to a
vanadis demands or suffer the
consequences after that meeting about
two hours after that beating avenatti
the sir decided to turn up the key on IP
he should the tweet and it said
something told me that we have not
reached the end of this scandal and I
scandal he's talking about the
college-basketball corruption
prosecution's brought the Southern
District of New York
the scandal it's likely far for our
broader than imagined why this tweet
went out to the public it was intended
and designed for audience of blong this
was Michael avenatti shot across Nikes
bow
through the alleged course of conduct
avenatti use legal terms like claims and
settlements and retainers but these were
mere devices to provide cover for a
vanadis extortion at demands for a
massive payday for himself by engaging
in the conduct alleged in the complaint
avenatti was not acting as an attorney a
suit-and-tie
doesn't mask the fact that at its core
this was an old-fashioned shakedown the
charges announced today reflect the hard
work not only in this office but our law
enforcement partners at the Federal
Bureau of Investigation to my left is my
good friend Jill Sweeney the assistant
director in charge of the FBI's New York
field office I want to thank him and his
team for their professionalism and
seeing this investigation through I want
to acknowledge and thank the career
prosecutors and agents of my office for
their role in the investigation and
prosecution of this case to my right is
Matt Podolski Robert Rob Solomon and
their supervisor in the public
corruption unit Edward discount the
talent and professionalism of these
dedicated public servants is is really
extraordinary our legal system our
system of justice requires and relies on
attorneys members of the bar to not
simply follow the law but uphold its
finest principles and ideals but when
lawyers use their long licenses as
weapons as a guise to extort payments
for themselves they are no longer acting
as attorneys they are acting as
criminals and they will be held
responsible for their conduct I'd now
like to invite bill Sweeney to the
podium
and it's Jeff earlier this afternoon
Michael avenatti was arrested in
Manhattan for the charges just outlined
by the US attorney this is nothing more
than a straightforward case of extortion
and as a result mr. avenatti was placed
into custody and brought to the FBI
offices of 26 Federal Plaza for a rest
processing in the event that anybody
needs to be reminded this type of
behavior is illegal and it will not be
tolerated
especially when committed by a lawyer
who was supposed to use his license to
practice law not to willfully violate it
thank you to the FBI personnel George
Matt and the rest of your team that's
still on the street who conducted the
investigation discreetly professionally
and quickly and thank you Jeff to your
team who stands my right I thank you for
your dedication professionalism thank
you we'll take your question extortion
is when you threaten to do something for
a thing of value and you don't have a
right of plausible right to that thing
of value so here avenatti was not
extorting in terms of seeking money for
a client he was seeking money for
himself
his obligations that's true
our investigation is continuing there
any plans to
our investigation is continuing
avenatti was arrested at the location
where the Monday meeting was supposed to
occur a few hours ago yes no comment our
investigation is continuing the cases
are entirely separate those are
financial related cases this is an
extortion case that began less than a
week ago the the arrest was coordinated
between the two officers but the
investigations and charges are entirely
separate I expect that he will be
presented before California Court I'm
not it's not clear no comment
no comment thanks Michael in the Michael
Holden case we see unrelated given his
fame and just have how hot profile that
he is at this point what would you say
to anyone who might say my greatest
questions that there might be some kind
of motivation motivation or anything
like that right this office doesn't take
politics into account when it decides to
charge a case and as you can see from
the timeline as I just went over we
received the call six days ago by the
victim saying that there was
extortionist threats made against them
and that's how we became involved in
this case thank you